Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert
Krulwich. This is Radiolab.
We're going to keep going with our show
on colors now with a story about, well,
hey blue, the color of the
sky, most beautiful color. No
red. Yeah. Yeah. You got it.
It's a story that we find
really surprising frankly.
And it comes from our producer Tim
Howard. Yes. Hello. Um, who, uh,
heard it from [inaudible]
set up who this guy is. Uh,
so Guy Deutscher is a
linguist and a writer and uh,
I came across his book or through the
language glass and he tells this one
particular story in it that, uh,
starts in I think 1858 with
this Guy William Gladstone,
who was incredibly famous
politician in England.
He was four times prime minister in
the second half of the 19th centuries.
Every school kid knows who he is even now.
But there's one thing that not many
people know about Gladstone, but he was a,
a home of fanatic. Those,
the soldiers marched.
The gleam went dazzling
from the magnificent bronze
all about through the upper
air to the heavens. He was a
deeply religious man. And for him,
the Iliad and Odyssey were almost like
a second Bible sipping the black blood,
the tall shade, perceive
pain and cried out shot.
He read them over and over
again throughout his life.
So he was in the homer.
Yes. And so early on in his career,
Gladstone decided to write the
definitive history of homer,
his huge book, actually three
books, thousands of pages way.
He discussed a whole range of issues
relating to home and his wallet.
And here's the thing, as he was reading,
doing his research and everything,
he made this very strange discovery.
[inaudible]
that's the way home I talks
about [inaudible] in the Iliad.
And the Odyssey is extremely
odd. It's odd. Very, very odd.
How so? To start with uses
extremely strange times,
four colors of, of simple objects. The
most famous one perhaps is the wine,
dark sea, the wine, wine, dark wine,
dark seats eight. It looks like wine.
Looks like wine. It is, it possibly
like a, a poetic kind of thing.
And that's what you would naturally
think. But the other thing he calls, um,
wine color, uh, oxen,
but, but it's more than just
a wine take the color violet,
which to me and probably to universal
purple like purple. And homer uses it.
He talks about the sheep
and the side clubs.
Rams were in the cyclops caves
is having a dark violent wool.
But that's just fantasy. I mean,
but the other thing that he also
says is violet is iron iron.
So chew on that or how about this one?
What is both the color of
honey and the color of, uh,
faces Pale with fear. I had
no idea. If you ask homer,
those are green, green honey.
He didn't call his green, he
didn't call his leaves green. Um,
it all seems to be wrong. And, um,
this was totally puzzling to Gladstone.
Hobo was Gladstone's absolute hero.
So he found it difficult to understand
and accept why someone who was so
perceptive would use such defective
terms as Gladston colleague.
So he starts going through the Iliad
and the Odyssey again and page by page,
and he counts how many
times each color appears.
I mean like how many times he uses the
word black or blue or whatever. Yeah.
And um, it only takes a couple
pages for him to notice.
Predominance of black and white that
the term black carrion flat black Bros,
black, black, black, black, black,
black occurred about 170
times in both books. White,
white arms, white club, the white
curd about 100 times.
But red blood,
red serpent only clocks in at about 13
times the red wine to the exotic Trump,
yellow in her yellow robe
row under 10 times Greens,
teeth chattering, green
fear also under 10 mm.
And then Gladstone realizes
something crazy, the color blue,
um,
zero times what there's just no word
that describes the color blue in any of
Homer's poems. He does not use
the word blue at all. No blue,
no blue. Not even once. Nope.
So Gladstone Thought, Huh?
Bazaar. And he started looking
in other classic Greek texts too.
And there he kept finding all
of these strange uses of color,
violet hat and things like that.
And after thinking about
this for a long time,
Gladstone concluded that
homo was kind of blind,
but also that all the Greeks
were kind of blind. We,
he thought all of them
were colorblind. Yes.
That they saw the world in black and
white, maybe with a touch of red.
His thought was that they were straining
to see these other colors that were
kind of just outside of their reach.
And then their kid would inherit that
effort or their kid would just be a little
bit better. Oh. So
that's how we got color.
So homer junior would be able
to see a little bit of yellow,
cause homer tried really hard to
see yellow and you then homer,
the third would be better than home or
the second and then this would happen
again. And again, every generation
down 3000 years to the present day,
it just seemed the only, you know,
the, the only possible explanation.
That's ridiculous. It's ridiculous.
We know today of course,
seven that, that the color vision goes
back probably about 30 million years,
you know, to like when we were still
in the jungle climbing trees. Exactly.
So I'm generally people Ma
[inaudible].
No one took him seriously.
So then how do people explain the
no blue and homer thing? Well, here,
the plot thickens. 10 years after
Gladstone's homered debacle.
This other guy and gentleman, Jewish
penologist called Lazarus guy again,
Lazarus Geiger, a German
Jewish, what did he say?
Philologists which I
thought was a linguist.
It basically means he
studies ancient texts.
He finds pretty much the same
kind of weird stuff Gladstone did,
but he finds it not just an ancient Greek
texts, but all over the place. Sorry,
this one, he looked at
the old Icelandic Sagas
[inaudible] ancient Chinese Joan
Susa. Young, ancient vedic hymns.
[inaudible] Stephie, the Bible
[inaudible] and surprise, surprise.
What did he find there? No blue.
Even the Bible had no blood
in the original Hebrew
[inaudible] Vinnie of Hahaha.
It has no blue. Huh? So where,
what's this? What's this room?
Right now we're in the
public catalog room.
I actually went to the New York public
library and talked to this librarian and
to Vic [inaudible] can speak German,
so and fic long can shake the dementia.
And we got out Geiger's book development,
history of mankind. Wait a second.
I know this voice. Really? Yeah,
that's, that's my girlfriend. Oh,
my name is Brooke Watkins and I'm a
librarian at the New York public library.
She is a librarian. Very cool
passenger. Does speak to daggers books.
See at first let's do it in German. Guy
Again has this amazing quotation. Okay.
It's fast. You hear about the Indian
vedic poems, these Alita [inaudible],
Jane towels and vans and
[inaudible]. What does that say?
She's hymns of more than 10,000 lines
are brimming with descriptions of the
heavens. Scarcely. Is there any
subject evoked more frequently?
The Sun and reddening. Don's play of
color, day and night. Cloud. Enlightening.
The air in the ether and efs are
unfolded before us and over and over in
splendor. And did it fullness. Well,
there's only one thing that no one would
ever learn from those ancient songs who
do not already know it. And
that is that the sky is blue.
Who? Who?
It gets weirder. Hmm. You're ready? Yeah.
Ready for this and totally ready.
Alright. Cause Geiger then wondered,
all right, if there's no blue
in any of these old texts,
then when did blue come
into these languages? Yeah,
so he did this massive analysis to
trace when each color term was first
introduced to each language.
And what he found was that the order at
which languages seem to acquire these
kind of Thames is not entirely random.
[inaudible]
first black and white. Every
language has black and white.
Then when they get their first
color term, red always comes fast.
Always red after red. It's
always yellow. Really? Yeah.
And then green and blue only to
very end. So black, white, red,
green, yellow and then blue.
Yeah. And that's universal. Well,
as people discovered more and more
languages, they found some exceptions,
but a couple of things held even
from Geiger out of these colors.
Red Is always first and
blue is always last. Why?
Well, why would there be an order at
all and why would blue always be last?
Well, here's where you get
to the guessing part. Okay.
Thinks it might have to do with a couple
of things. First in Homer's world,
you wouldn't have actually been exposed
to a lot of blue things. Actually,
if you think about it, blue is
extremely rare in nature. Blue Foods,
no blue animals know. How about
plants? There's a few blue plants,
like what flowers it I really
blue eyes. Extremely rare.
A lot of flowers that we think of as
blue. They're actually artificial flowers.
We made them blue genetically
man. Yeah. What about Blue Eyes?
Blue Eyes at the time. Way In
short supply. I'm among the Greeks,
but here's where we get
to guy's main point.
He says you don't really need a word
for color until you can make that color
reliably and the reason they're red
might have been first is that red is
apparently one of the easiest to produce.
You can just take a dried piece of
red clay and you can use that as a
[inaudible],
which is why paints made out of oak or
go back something like 60,000 years and
blue. Blue is the hardest of
all. For thousands of years.
No one had it. One exception, the
Egyptians, the Egyptians, and they,
and only they had their own word for
blue. So that's it. That's your answer.
Yeah. Like no blue dyes. No blue words.
That's not interesting. I want more
than that. What do you mean more?
I don't know. Something more to
say than just it's about all right,
here you go.
As I was calling around,
I ran into something that made me think
a little differently about Gladstone's
whole theory of colorblindness
called this guy named Jules Davidoff,
professor of newest
psychology, London University,
and a few years back he got interested
in this particular tribe in Namibia
called the Himba Himba many
languages in the world.
They don't have a different word for blue.
You might think of them as like a very
poor stand in for homer. All right,
and to make a long story
short, Joseph went to Namibia.
He sat down with a bunch of
members of the Himba tribe,
whipped out a laptop and
showed them 12 colored squares,
or I didn't except for one.
And there's actually some really cool
video footage of his research assistant
doing this and they
asked them very simply,
which one is different now that you
look at this and you see the 11 of these
squares are green [inaudible]
we would call green, very green.
The other one is blue. This blue one,
it's, it's shouting. It's like, Hey,
I'm bayou over here. I'm blue.
It's easy enough for us to do.
It would be, yeah, it's a no brainer,
but the Himba who don't have a separate
word for blue in their language,
they find this distinction
and that are difficult.
When they stare at this screen,
they just stare and stare.
They don't see the difference.
They don't know was there something
wrong with their eyes. Now,
definitely not completely rule that out.
They don't see color and
individual colors differently,
but then it's so easy to say that they're
seeing different colors to us and then
not, well then how does he
explain it? Okay. When we,
when we decide to put colors together
in a group and then give those colors a
word like blue, something
happens. He says,
what happens is that now that
there's a category for that thing,
the thing in the category jumps out,
it gets louder and louder to your eyes.
The category actually feeds back on
your perception. So you notice it more.
You're saying that having the word for
blue unlocks your ability to see blue.
I mean it, that's how it feels
to me. And jewel says no,
it's not caught that he
says without the word,
you're still seeing the blue no
matter what. You're just not. Um,
noticing it.
Your eyes are just kind of glossing
right over it so you don't see it.
It's hard. It's, it's, it's harder
to spot. It says jewels, whatever.
I don't quite understand that difference.
But blue would not jump out and say
high five the way it does with us.
But if it doesn't jump out to that extent,
then this is starting to
sound very Gladstone to me.
I mean maybe he was a little right. Like,
cause if homer had no
word for blue in the word,
somehow enables the blueness of the blue,
then maybe his world was less
blue than it would be for us.
I mean maybe the blue went
through his eyes in the same way,
but perhaps didn't get into
his mind in the same way. Yeah.
Blue didn't matter.
Wait a second. Do you know
where this breaks down?
Where deaf sky.
I mean you look up and there's the bluest
blue in the world and it's right there
above our head. It's been
there since the dawn of time.
So why wouldn't blue matter more? I mean,
why wouldn't it be the first
color instead of the last? Well,
that's what I thought too. And
I asked guy about that. Yeah.
Why is the sky blue? Is, is the, the,
the first question is that you allegedly,
the first question that
all children ask. Yeah,
but I wanted to see how obvious or
striking this blueness of the skies.
So I decided to make an experiment.
Uh,
guy has a very young daughter, 18
months. She was learning to speak.
What's her name? Um,
I talked a lot about colors with
Emma and taught her all the colors,
including blue.
And we would play all these games
there that dads play with the children,
you know, pointing at objects. I would
point it to a blue object and ask him,
what's the color of this? She would say
boom boo for blue. A. Okay. Soon enough,
Alma is a total pro. She could identify
any color, show me the red object,
show me the destiny. Right.
The only thing I didn't do,
and I asked my wife not to do, was
ever mentioned that the sky was blue.
That was the setup.
So one day guy and Elmo were taking a
stroll and they're practicing the colors.
What's the street?
What's this, what's this?
And then I pointed at the sky
and said, what kind of is that?
And she wouldn't give
me any answer. Huh? Oh,
does she just a second before would was
happily telling me that something was
blue on red or green.
She just looked up and looked at me
in comprehending Dingley sort of,
what are you talking about?
Cheetah? You're kidding.
I think she didn't understand what
I was on about. Huh? In retrospect,
there was no object that there
was nothing with color for her.
You're just pointing into the void,
basically pointing into nothingness.
So she wouldn't say anything,
but guy kept asking every
single time they went out.
And once I would do it only when the
sky was blue and she would never answer.
And this went on for two months.
And then finally she did consent to give
me a color name, but it wasn't blue.
It was white for for a
few times you said white.
And then finally after a month
and a half or two moments,
she said blue for the first time. Wow.
Even then it wasn't consistently
blue. So she then she said once blue,
no white, no blue. Did she eventually
decide though? You know what that is?
Blue wasn't, no, she
never said it this way,
but eventually when I asked
it became consistently do it.
So she just would say blue. Okay.
This was for me really the point
where I, I could, you know,
convince myself,
I convinced at least my heart that this
sort of allegedly perfect example of
blue, um, is not so perfect.
So you know, for Houma who,
you know,
never ever probably saw a blue
object except the sky and the sea,
never had a dad who sort of went on and
bought blue objects and asking them what
they kind of, this guy was the fact
that he didn't lose sleep over.
It doesn't seem so strange anymore.
You know, it's kind of, it's a, now
that I've heard this, I'm a little,
I'm a little, uh, ruining the,
the moment when Alma
decided the sky was blue,
let her have whatever
color she wants it to be.
Doesn't have to be blue weirdly
then color is a loss of innocence.
Yeah.
It's Kinda like having something fixed
that for awhile it's just between you and
your friends, he'd hearts, you know,
this guy has many colors. Truthfully,
on the other hand though, I'm
disagreeing with myself now.
If we all agree the sky is blue,
then that's something we can
share that she can share.
And then she's in conversation and then
eventually she'll understand, you know,
this kind of blue,
um, uh,
[inaudible]
[inaudible] yeah, they
weren't close by but there,
but you know what one would know
what it feels like in the yeah,
it's not a happy night.
[inaudible]
Guardian Stove. The dollars.
Hello. Your Day.
That last
you [inaudible]
he lost all his good day. You said
No.
And these two are turn to blue
like Kim.
I am doubtful that your love is
sure too.
D side too.
Call me.
Call me is too blue. It's the
most beautiful color. [inaudible]
ah, I just took red just to be contrary.
I'm fine if you would call
it. Use It only when you say
love me. [inaudible] man,
prove it by gone out on the slide.
[inaudible]
did you [inaudible]
call me is
[inaudible]
I want to thank all the musicians who
were so generous to let us use their music
this hour and joined in and our
covers of the rainbow project.
You heard Reggie Watts
with rainbow connection.
Barbara Benary with over the rainbow,
lonesome organists with green onions,
nymph with brown rice,
yellow ostrich with sound and RIAA brass
band with painted black Nico Muli with
big yellow taxi shearwater
with black as the color.
Eric Freelander with blue in green. Marci
playground with whiter shade of Pale,
the heat with mellow yellow
Tao Wynn with blue snow. Blink.
You just heard with Blue Moon Dan
Deacon right here with colors.
Busman's holiday, Mr Blue and our
very own Tim Howard, Aka Soul Taro
[inaudible].